hey 42 here North Korea is officially
the most corrupt country in the world
the Corruption Perceptions Index ranks
every country in the world from zero to
a hundred based on how corrupt it is
with a score of zero being very corrupt
and a hundred meaning very clean every
year North Korea ties with Somalia for
last place let's uncover the most
disturbing facts about the world's
favorite Hermit Kingdom North Korea or
more officially known as the Democratic
People's Republic of Korea has the
fourth largest army in the world with
1.2 million active members not far
behind America with its military of 1.4
million
there are 28 states approved haircuts in
North Korea women are allowed to choose
from one of 18 styles married women are
instructed to choose shorter styles
while single ladies are permitted to let
loose with a longer style men on the
other hands are allowed to choose from
one of ten state approved haircuts all
of which are short all North Korean men
are prohibited from growing their hair
longer than 5 centimeters
north Korea has an impressive 100%
literacy rate literacy is defined as
individuals aged 15 and over who can
read and write there are 25,000 554
kilometers of roads in North Korea but
only 724 kilometers are paved
that's a measly 2.8 3% the Korean
Demilitarized Zone or DMZ is a strip of
land 250 kilometers long that separates
South Korea from North Korea it was set
up as a neutral zone where the two
countries could safely discuss matters
at the end of the Korean War in
53 despite its name it is the most
heavily militarized border in the world
soldiers guarding the DMZ are ordered to
shoot anyone trying to sneak in or out
of the country making China the most
popular escape route for North Koreans
80% of defectors are women however an
unlikely good has come out as such a
heavily militarized border the Korean
DMZ strip is home to some of the most
critically endangered species of animals
and plants on earth whom have found an
unlikely haven protected from any human
contact
extremely rare species such as the
Korean tiger the elusive and more
leopard and the Asiatic black bear have
all found a home here amongst the land
mines and listening-posts
ecologists have identified some 2900
plant species seventy types of mammals
and 320 kinds of birds within this
narrow strip of land the South Korean
government has campaigned to Eunice Cote
numerous times to turn the DMZ into a
nature reserve to protect the endangered
animals but every time North Korea has
declined to make such an agreement in
the 50s North Korea built kachunk dong
on North Korea's side of the DMZ so it
was easily visible from South Korea
which North Korea claimed was the
perfect City the city supposedly
contained a childcare center
kindergarten primary and secondary
schools as well as a hospital the idea
was to make the city appear so
attractive that it enticed South Koreans
to defect to North Korea however after
observation from the South Korean side
of the DMZ it became obvious that the
city is actually completely uninhabited
and has remained so ever since it was
built it has since come to be known as
propaganda village
in the 1980s the South Korean government
built a 98 meter tall flagpole on the
south side of the DMZ close to the
border the North Korean government
responded by building an even taller one
inky Jang dong in what some have called
the flagpole war at the time it was the
second tallest flagpole in the world in
the past 60 years over 23,000 North
Koreans have defected to South Korea
whereas only
two South Koreans have gone north of the
border
north Korea has its own operating system
called red star OS it's a fork of Linux
most of the software on there such as
the web browser text editor and firewall
are custom programs written by North
Korea in 1974 kim ill sung took 1000
volvo sedans from Sweden to North Korea
and never paid for them
in 2013 current North Korean leader Kim
jong-un executed his uncle along with
five of his aides by locking them in a
cage and feeding them to a starving pack
of a hundred and twenty dogs but what
had Kim's uncle done to deserve such a
horrific demise well Kim accused his
uncle of mismanaging the economy
corruption womanizing and taking drugs
marijuana is completely legal in North
Korea and is not even classified as a
drug it is commonly used for medicinal
purposes North Korea is the only nation
on earth to currently have a US Navy
ship captured it isn't 2015 in North
Korea it is the year 104 counted after
the birth of Kim jong-un's grandfather
and founder of the DPRK kim ill sung
north korea is home to the world's
largest stadium the impressive made a
stadium seats
150,000 people it is home to the annual
Aryan Games which is one of the most
spectacular displays of coordination and
choreography on earth the Ruby Jung
hotel in North Korea is a 105 storey
building that for 20 years held the
title of the world's tallest hotel
construction began in 1987 but was
halted before it finished in 1992 as
North Korea entered a period of economic
crisis following the fall of the Soviet
Union the monstrosity now towers over
Pyongyang and stands completely empty
the only people allowed to own vehicles
in North Korea are the military and
government officials transport in
general is tightly controlled North
Korean citizens are generally restricted
from traveling anywhere at all even
inside their own country
North Korea's Space Agency is called
nada which in Spanish means nothing it
stands for national aerospace
development administration the program
only has a 20 percent success rate
wearing jeans is illegal in North Korea
because denim symbolizes the DPRK 's
enemy the United States every five years
North Korea holds a general election in
which the ballot papers lists only one
candidate in 2012 North Korea officially
announced that it had discovered a
unicorn layer the always trustworthy
DPRK is official news agency released a
statement claiming that they had found a
cave 200 metres from Pyongyang city with
a rectangular Rock in front of it with
the words unicorn lair conveniently
carved into it they believe the unicorn
was rode by an ancient Korean king named
King Tong hyung
North Korea is dotted with prison labor
camps where prisoners are reportedly
subjected to horrific inhumane treatment
prisoners of these concentration camps
suffer a level of slavery torture and
experimentation comparable with the
Holocaust although North Korea denies
the existence of such camps insider
sources claim there are 16 such camps
across the country home to 200,000
prisoners in total North Korea also has
a free generations of punishment law
this means that anyone sent to a prison
camp is sent along with their entire
family regardless if they were involved
in the crime or not also any family
members born whilst in prison will live
their entire lives there as well as any
children they may have whilst in prison
two North Koreans are subject to a six
day workweek as well as a seventh day of
supposed volunteer work which is also
strictly enforced
meaning North Koreans have virtually no
free time official records show that Kim
Jong Il learnt to work at the age of
three weeks and was talking at eight
weeks while studying at Kim il-sung
University he reportedly wrote 1,500
books over a period of three years along
with six full operas according to his
official biography all of his operas are
better than any in the history of music
it is also written in Kim Jong Il's
biography that he was born under a
double rainbow and to mark his birth
there was a new star and a swallow in
the sky it is also written that he could
control the weather and make it rain on
command
depending on his mood in fact the list
of questionable claims and feats of
press surrounding the North Korean
leader are endless schoolchildren are
required to learn everything
about their current leader as well as
his two predecessors even if the
so-called facts may be a bit on the
fabricated side thanks for the view
subscribe for more 42